bien sûr les délinquants autour de la
table
raymond raconte le téléspectateur tu as
été convoqué par la police la
gendarmerie ou la maréchaussée donc hier
tu as reçu un coaching ouais t'as dit
qu'on voit vente hier avant-hier vous
êtes convoqué c'est ça ouais ouais pour
je reçois un coup de fil bonjour sept
commissariats est-ce que vous pouvez
venir dans nos locaux cette troisième
soirée pour nom suite à une enquête
judiciaire qui a été ouvert à votre
encontre bagages n'ont pas venir tout de
suite parce que je travaille mais demain
si vous voulez juin demain et donc j'y
vais demain j'y vais le lendemain donc
il hier bah je vais dans les locaux tout
se passe bien quelle identité je monte
au première étage échoué auditionné pour
une histoire de carreau cassé un carreau
cassé quatre places
[Applaudissements]
remplacer des chamailleries c'est un
carreau qui se casse c'est chamakh et
ouais c'est un carreau qui se casse mais
à valence et quoi et c'est à dire
une grande vitrine dans un immeuble qui
appartient à une mairie
donc du coup le bon bah du coup c'est
l'amérique il faut rembourser mais avant
quand tu faisais ça tu chama étude qu as
tu t'en fous sauf que maintenant quand
tu passes à la télé les gens et ont vu
les jeunes mousses et
laissez-la brut il vivra oui mais j'ai
pas fait exprès mais c'est la routine
livreur qui a cassé nord je me suis pas
cassé des carreaux dans la rue comme ça
c est donc cette très bonne mais
kick-ass shippuden ils sont 10 l abruti
de livres armez vous laissez pas vos
coordonnées quand même j'ai oublié
et à côté ça fait est là bas là je ils
ont demandé au procureur si ça
s'arrêtait là parce qu'ils ont rappelé
le procureur
il avait dix sept siècles aurait jeté
avec le pg l'officier de police
judiciaire dans un gars bien on a fait
un questionnaire sur ma vie et m'a
demandé combien vous me payez or mère
j'étais payé
parce que quand il fait l'enquète je
suppose qu'ils veulent me mettre une
amende derrière mais le soir le
procureur pourquoi il a pas droit six
combats pour l'amender l'objet de me
demander mes revues c'est ce qu'a dû
tourner à paris
on n'est pas du tout et tu t'es pas
arrêtés complètent ce départ était
content mais moi jamais moi je me suis
fait engueuler mais parce que je le sais
j'étais restée
ici est juste et bonne ici toi oui il
d'avoir atteint grand mère
[Applaudissements]
tennis et wii on n'a pas le droit de lui
demander tous ces détails sachez que moi
je m'en foutais j'ai tout dit j'ai dit
mme montas fin livraison j'espère aussi
qu'on pense que j'avais avec lui je
demandais comment j'allais me l'ont dit
pour vous habitez tellement loin à 60
bande des studios pourquoi de mecs vous
paye pas l'hôtel tous les soirs et
les ai trouvés c'est une bonne idée
il n'avait pas pensé je te donne les
appeler le nord
n'ont pas déçu pas les appeler et sympa
tu as compris le mec a fait une connerie
et on n'a pas encore décidé de son sort
et offert 3,500 un carreau 390 à 400
balles de carreaux j'aimerais bien qu'on
prête à négocier avec eux on peut le
maire négocie pas fait ce que
je voulais à sarlat c'est fermé la lopé
gilles est parti il finissait à 17 ans à
peine
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait de l'art un directoire raconte
aux gens j'ai fait de la radio avec toi
il ya dix ans à chaque fois que tu as
appelé un commissariat ouais je suis
parti pour 24 heures de garde à vue
est-ce qu'il était très simple et
raconte l'histoire c'est que moi j'avais
j'avais donc les condi qui m'appelait
bret qui dit oui et moi je dis non
vraiment c'est vraiment pas bien ce
qu'il
comprend tout à fait la garder le nom
mais ça lui ferait vraiment il faut lui
donner une leçon j'ai tout à fait
d'accord commence à venir le chercher
non écoutez donc j'ai pas que ça à
[ __ ] j'ai sorti mon pedigree
d'ailleurs ils m'ont dit vous êtes connu
des services de police une petite
bagarre en 2006 un petit truc vite fait
dans le 9e arrondissement
mais j'étais j'ai été la victime je me
suis fait agresser je me suis défendu et
puis bon là et comme il a porté plainte
en premier parce qu'il faut savoir si
vous faites agresser
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
écoutez les mec a envie de vider son sac
oui on a laissé je ne suis pas grèce
ils ont voulu que les maghrébins
est super important je me suis fait
agresser on sait castanea voilà moi je
suis parti le mec il est parti porter
plainte c'est le promets qu'ils portent
plainte car raison me suis retrouvé au
commissariat avec les menottes alors
alors que je me fais agresser ils m'ont
sorti tout mon pedigree d'hanouna le
matin non vous avez volé un bus
vous avez volé un bus d'être entré par
effraction au salon de l'agriculture
mais ça c'était pour faire des conneries
à la radio canada ouais et alors
j'aurais dis à chaque fois que tu appelé
le commissariat je raconte logeant il
appelait je disais je vous passe à
l'honneur moi j'étais content je dis aux
flics tenez je passe hanouna et lui
disait je ne connais je connais pas du
tout d'accord vous êtes qui vous et je
suis en train de travailler glissez la
police est alors ma grand mère a fait
des hommes là tôt si j'en ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
une fois sur une fausse livraison ça
faudra le refaire les fossiles raison on
fait une faute si je reçois excuse moi
[Applaudissements]
tu apprendras deux dentiers travail ça
va toi on a livré des poulets ça fait
combien de temps que tu as pas parler à
quelqu'un
[Rires]
c'est vrai quand tu te fais pas les
méchants oui je l'étais façon c'est quoi
votre anecdote ce que vous avez la plus
constante de votre j'ai eues dans top 3
des honte de ma vie depuis que je suis
en livraison et de salaire 28 ans j'ai
eu ce matin le top 2 le top 2 ça veut
dire que tout ça n'est pas souvent je
mange ans dans votre loge pour des trucs
en partant des îles à des barres
chocolatées des conneries et je mange
norvège oui bah vous me voyez quand je
vous dis au revoir je t'enlève n'est pas
venu nous voir un sticker samar symbole
typ je la prends la balle je tuais
facturés
elle arrête alors
c'est une caisse à l'autre
toujours des conneries et ce qui fait
que je les mange des beauty les machins
des stickers et mars et ce matin c'était
il ya deux jours déjà parce que je fais
milliards et ce matin ça commence je
sens que j'ai fait des conneries avec
mon corps j'ai envie de popo donne envie
liège ouais de ouf de pop au dos je me
dis tiens je vais bien réagi dans le
capteur voilà mais je sors d'autoroute
mais vraiment quand on sait que c'est
dans la dernière ligne droite on
n'arrivera pas au bout j'ai dit je vais
pas y arriver j'ai cru que j'ai tenu une
heure à rouler mellal et de l'esprit
nerfs de tous je l'étais non je suis
obligé de sortir de l'otan ont dit je
tiendrai pas et incluant que je livre
qui fait longue la sortie d'autoroute et
je m'arrêtais chez lui je veux lui dire
je bois un café comment ça va ça
boissons ce moment et je vais aller
défoncer ses toiles est vite fait je me
gare avec le camion je mets en et je
vais aux toilettes il salut ça va et ça
tombe sur un service gratuit et vegan
livraison se fait non il n'y a pas de
livraisons c'est pas pour ça que je veux
j'ai hâte annick je dépose doridant mais
mon arbre et elle veut me parler c'est
non mais tu étais je reviens je vous
montre je vais aux toilettes je me pose
aux toilettes et je me dis en a pour
deux secondes tellement j'ai envie c'est
quand on a bien beaucoup envie tu dis là
ça sort pour s'essuyer on se barre dans
l'oeil boire un café à emporter je me
casse présence et laver les mains c'est
vite fait genre je me suis forgé fait
pipi limite limite tu peux dire tu as
fais pipi n'était pas resté longtemps je
m'assois c'est un très beau témoignage
[Rires]
c'est juste avant cette anecdote à
autoroutes et fans attendent et vous
allez voir la première manche elle se
passe super g du joueur c'est comme
j'avais prévu je me lève et on a tous
connu ça tu te lèves et là ou là tu te
reçois
tout su et là j'ai un mal de ventre mais
ahmad de vente j'ai alors là je
participe pour une heure la hchouma la
meuf à flipper gens là pour un quart
d'heure et au bout de deux minutes
j'entends papa ça c'est le bus qui
arrivent pas tourner parce que mon
camion
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas pensé à ce [ __ ] je suis comme
ça en train de me plier pourquoi j'ai
dit vite vite vite le bus ça va faire un
embouteillage jusqu'à l'autoroute non
l'autoroute qu'est-ce que je pense après
l'autoroute la halle à l'intersection le
tramway le tramway peut pas passer non
et j'entends les gens qui rentrent dans
le restaurant bonjour il acquit le
camion qui est dehors
il est au livre mais je crois qu'il est
malade
je
la nuit des musées c'est rien c'est bien
c'est comme des débuts du cauchemar je
me dis ah les gens ils rentrent le mec
il commence à s'énerver voulu dit tout
de suite qui leur est son camion chargé
rendez-vous j'emmène les enfants à
l'école j'ai [ __ ] les enfants je me
lève au plus 13 mars
impossible une douleur comme si on
mettait des coups bas et je regardais je
regardais choix et le papier et je
regarde pas de papiers
ouvrir elle vient d'ouvrir le restaurant
papier chevaux vaches ardemment une
deuxième personne qui rentrent pas ce
que tu entends klaxonner de la rue
j'entends le bordel sont infusés
attend vraiment et un manège j'entends
le bordel que je suis en train de [ __ ]
les gens s'énervent oui c'est pas
possible en retard au boulot j'ai un
rendez vous il ya au moins cinq
personnes dans l'instant et bien jusque
là j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je me dis c'est
bon ça va on a le droit d'être malade
c'est bon ça va ça va se régler comme tu
dis ça va se passer souvent tu dis ça
quand ya des histoires ça va se tasser
jusqu'à ce que ça va se tasser et là
j'entends des voix que je connais
bonjour messieurs dames c'est acquis le
véhicule pied dehors non j'ai dit ça on
sait qui c'est qui parle comme ça y'a
pas 500 personnes qui parlent comme sa
police c'est ça qui est le véhicule qui
est dehors la police et la fille a dit
oui bonjour monsieur l'agencé amont de
chauffeur livreur il est dans les
toilettes il est coincé depuis tout à
l'heure non hélas talât bien mouche au
mollet s'ouvrait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à
je veux pas répond vous êtes là j'ai dit
je suis là mais je peux pas sortir
pourquoi on pouvait pas sortir j'ai
parce que j'ai mal au ventre eh ben vous
prenez votre camion vous enlevez votre
camion vous revenez après si c'est pas
un truc confiant plusieurs fois ci chant
des oiseaux seashore je vais faire par
terre je peux passer je peux suis désolé
deux minutes et me dit c'est 135 euros
non j'ai dit mam et et 135 euros et dure
la plage derrière c'est un cauchemar qui
sait ça comment vous êtes vous un
problème c'est ça c'est tu poses a
essuyé est ce que quelqu'un lui a serré
la main
autant entre temps il s'est passé mais
quand même bien tout ce que j'ai fait
mon truc d'essuyer ses j'ai enlevé mon
400 j'ai remis mon bleu de travail ce
que j'ai un autre bleu de travail dans
le camion et j'ai changé de lieu de
travail une fois maîtres essuyé chez un
autre client mais ça c'est plus
compliqué que vous êtes et du coup je
suis super doigt dans le cul
sur sorti comme ça navan au lavabo et
les policiers ils m'ont passé un savon à
s'améliorer
[Applaudissements]
voilà
[Rires]
l'anecdote ça va mal aux toilettes
pendant le film est bon les gars et vous
bien quand vous allez aux toilettes
garez vous plaît
on tombe sur
des gens là pas de camion
[Rires]